bonsoir blondy j'ai travaillé pendant
dix ans val qui pendant dix ans je t'ai
vu rue des lombards ça fait combien de
temps que des gens barros à 30 30 ans et
j'ai jamais aux est abordé dans
l'émission la télé j'étais invité
remarquer d'accord ça fait je suis papa
par imagine comme ça qu'un jour un soir
je croise dans la rue d'en bas
et puis j'ai envie que j'ai envie de toi
oui du site aborde comme ça dans la rue
et je te dis qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est
ce que tu me proposes mais ça dépend un
jeu tout le monde d'accord ce qu'est ce
que tu veux je te fasse un nom c'est ça
tu vas de nous dire aussi un petit peu
je peux faire des choses un peu en
vigueur non pas celle des ports oui si
tu me le demande
chez les filles c'est quoi ta spécialité
était surtout machiste
ah ben oui tu peux faire quoi tu connais
fouetté par les fous et evry
comme tu veux je peux t'attacher jeu et
après tu ma tâche sur un lit tout
attaché sur un lit sur une croix en bois
seront fait une croix chez toi origine
on est obligé de laisser tourner tout le
matériel chez moi donc tu peux
m'attacher surnombre en bois façon quoi
te mettre dans un cercueil à l'occasion
d'un mariage est un cercle même dans une
cage avec moquerie grille du temps pour
qu'ils puissent les cours m6 a annoncé
qu est-ce qui fait mal aux jambes
rihaoui a fait un bond à vouloir mater
qui borde la terre est défendable
il ya des gens qui te demandes ce bail
avec 91 plusieurs le truc le plus fou
comment est ce que demander sa belle
c'est d'avoir ouvert les bons vraiment
là oui mais tu les ouvre avec rabin ou
alors j'ai un petit bijou est une lame
de rasoir sa défense je ne fais pas ça
comme une bouchère bien simon 1
j'essaie tout vraiment je suis bon avec
terre je vais pas m'amuser à faire bram
à écouter ouvrir les portes comme ça non
j'y vois là d'abord je le constate je me
transforme en docteur alors je lui
demande d'abord on met fait m'avoir ou
es ce que vous avez vraiment mal alors
il dit voilà schéma là non je vois je
fais mon diagnostic j'ai dit voilà
monsieur vous avez avec piste sur une
partie bon alors je veux voir si
vraiment moche de fâcheux lui redonne
rendez vous diront quand ils reviennent
dit je suis d'accord je veux tout le faz
bon à lens une étudiante je prends que
j'habille l'infirmière
moi je m'habille en chirurgie n y vois
que mes yeux est bon alors je transforme
ou de l'appartement en bloc opératoire
est alors là bon ben je fais rentrer par
un unique client le malade parce que je
considère comme un malade et dès que je
prends au monde bistouri où ma lame de
rasoir automatiquement quand je peux
bonchamp fine une entaille hop il
éjacule alors le jeu est terminé
un bon voilà il ya combien de gens un
peu près où tu pratiques selon bah ça
dépend ça c'est des gens en général
qu'ils recherchaient une sensation forte
qu on trouve pas chez eux ou qu'ils ont
d'autres problèmes qui veulent se sentir
supérieur voilà tu vas pas peur quand
par exemple 1 6 les parties d'un homme
comme ça que tu touches le sens
d'attraper des maladies maintenant un
enjeu mitterrand jibidar encore comme
une infirmière comme un docteur tout
avec soin tout est stérilisé tous les
instruments
[Musique]
et les autorités savent que tu fais ça
je le savais mais maintenant le jeune
exercé plus j'ai arrêté parce que
quelquefois des personnages comme moi on
a tendance à venir voir de quel genre de
personne que je monte alors j'ai préféré
stopper que des gens connus dans ce
climat on veut non je ne sais pas je
connais pas on se présente pas avec une
carte d'identité chez moi mais dis donc
si tu si tu as tâche des gens sur une
croissance à vapeur ce soit un peu
sacrilège combat devient sur sa tombe
dans le domaine sacrilège c'est
l'inconscient je le fais toi tu es pas
croyant si je suis croyante j'étais lui
chez les religieuses jusqu'à 21 ans
c'est vrai je suis sorti de chez les
religieuses et les vingtaine ont déjà
commencé quand même pas après quatre
jours après oui c'est vrai le premier
que j'ai rencontré malheureusement
personam
c'était un proxénète notoire en sortant
de ce moment dans un renseignement pour
une ruche et je sentais que j'avais
encore mon chaque clé dans mon sac je
connaissais rien du tout c'était la
prédestination voilà c'était ma vie mais
ça choque pas tes sentiments religieux
des chablis non et non pas du tout on
reste toujours les clients à qui tu fais
tout ça blondissez des clients réguliers
ou cdc des clients qui s'y dit qu'il ya
un sérieux c'est pas des gens que tu
rencontres chose qui m'avait demandé
avant et après on en arrive mais c'est
jamais arriver quelqu'un que tu
rencontres pour la première fois te
demanderas choses comme ça jusqu ici ici
un client peut demander une chose
normale c'est-à-dire juste de fermer mon
normalement t'es d'accord où tu lui dit
écoutez moi je lui réponds que c'est
lassant pourrait faire autre chose ouais
tu lui dis que toi tu non je vais faire
mais j'ai dit je trouve que faire autre
chose que toujours pareil incident
rituel alors ça c'est pas trop d'accord
non ans avoue combien un truc très
compliqué style le sérieux je suis de
l'acadie revers concédés face garde la
personne j'en ai foi d'une journée ah
bah oui parce que des fois il ya des
passerelles faire parce que je trouve
vraiment dans le jeu
bon bah quand j'ai fait des petits
points de se dire que je rejoue avec
l'éguille bon il faut que je fasse des
pansements et tout
moi c'est un malade je le soigne comme
si j'étais elle docteur voilà je
conserve chez moi de journée au juge en
fait repartir le lendemain
des fois il des gens qui restent
plusieurs jours des joueurs gênés 2 oui
j'étais enfermé dans un cercueil à bord
il y en a qui restent dans le cercueil
il reste après avoir déjà pu les voir
des gens blessés de même que me demande
une journée entière ou c'est moi même
qui donne la punition ah bon il ya eu
quelque chose de pas bien fait ou de mal
dit sur moi même qui enferme la personne
mais comment t'est arrivé à faire ça
enfin au début je le faisais normalement
puis après j'ai voulu me spécialiser
coûte vraiment chercher une spécialité
alors je me suis trouvé ton très mal à
payer ce que c'était vraiment pour moi
et dans la rue il ya beaucoup de deux
sites du français je suis non je suis là
c'est la seule et à paris tu pense que
oui il y en a beaucoup qui pratique et
les gens fin sans trahir le secret les
gens qui viennent me voir c'est plutôt
des gens qui m'aiment pas rien à redire
bien ils sont plutôt jeunes plutôt nagy
tous les âges
il ya des jeunes ce même de 20 il y en a
de 20 ans homme de 20 ans a dénoncé
chaque garçon qui vit ça jacasse me
voilà c'est tout et après tu vas faire
ça change quand même temps je ne sais
pas ça me plaît bien le faire c'est mon
métier voilà tu prends du plaisir trois
personnes
bon je ne rentrent pas dans le jura mort
mais quand même j'aime bien le faire
voilà quand on me le demande je rentre
dans mon jeu quelques fois parce que se
soulagent la personne je vois je lui
fait du bien moralement et tout est géré
par deux chez moi heureux si l'on vient
chercher chez moi quelque chose que
comme je vous le dis qu'il n'a pas
ailleurs
ou alors de tête tout contraignant
ailleurs alors ce que je lui fait subir
moi mes services et ben il sent plus
période pour affronter ce qu'ils paient
récent de la plupart voilà tu penses tu
as une fonction parce que la vie parce
que medica a priori nécessaire
tu fais quoi d'autre dans la vie à part
ça je veux dire quand tu quand tu fais
passer le temps et quand même jour par
semaine pour jay des petits faiseurs r
je commençais à 6 heures le matin 6
heures le matin où les clients oui c'est
bien c'est son mot c'est noir cela passe
évidemment et puis jusqu'à deux heures
de l'après midi
ouais voilà pierre prévost chevigny
j'écris tu habites dans l'appartement où
tu te seras non pas du tout je ferme la
porte à clé c'est terminé jean mimi
voilà je suis un autre personne à un
autre appartement où tu m'aimes s'est
terminée vissage voilà et tu arrives à
mettre beaucoup d'argent de côté quand
même non pas tellement parce que
l'argent de la prostitution au cic
l'argent du diable comme voilà je le
dépense tout va mal tu ignores pas ça
donne je donne pas quelqu'un à vannes
ont heureusement alors je lui fais mais
plus maintenant maintenant mon âge j'ai
fait mes preuves dans le métier quand
même je fais un livre oui j'écris la
prostitution telle qu'elle était telle
qu'elle se faisait telle qu'elle
existait voilà
s'appelle comment tendre la main qg même
accusé par la scène bien sûr celle qui a
été souillé par tout ce que j'ai pu
subir dans ma vie par l'homme qui m'a
fait un déjà connus devraient amour avec
un mac
bon quand j'étais jeune mais plus
maintenant 10 ans sont morts ses cendres
mais des fois quand tu fais un petit
client t'as pas envie non pas du tout il
y en a qui te propose de sortir de là
non plus je voudrais parce que c'est pas
la peine je me plais dans mon métier tu
as des regrets d'avoir fait ce métier
pas du tout c'était ma foi ça c'était à
refaire je referais la même chose
pareille
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous y mettez un
peu de bleu